so we're doing a cup test with you yeah
this lightweight is going to punch you
in the cup is that all right i told
aaron it was a lightweight
i didn't tell him it was a heavy weight
that's not a flight wait what are you
guys talking about
you lied to me i meant heavyweight but
lightweight came out
i'm a ufc fan so i heard francis and
goner was going to be there and i was
like i want to do it please please and
then later i found out in fact i didn't
want to do it
i just googled the hardest punch ever
recorded his punch is the equivalent of
being hit by a ford escort at top speed
why you don't need to read that now
[Laughter]
you waited until the fourth theatrical
release to become a real star
[Music]
you